yo were here at blacker house where you
spent your undergraduate undergraduate
years where you were molded into the
physicists you are today Caltech is the
physics Marines and we're here at dinner
time I hope you remember what it was
like and I'm sure you had many fine
meals here and the food I'm told it's
much better than it used to be
let me just sample a little bit of it
here water please
okay yeah
foods awesome like it used to be I'm
sure your day anyways you're famous at
blacker house for the prank that that
you perform I understand you stole the
door to the roof access of the Milliken
library I think if the tenth floor of
the Milliken Library and it was it was a
heroic effort articularly had to climb
through an air shaft or something to get
one floor above but blacker house is
resourceful and they are known for it
anyways I hope you enjoyed your years at
Cal Tech and the students here at
blacker house want to give you their
regards
here at the squash courts at Cal Tech
and I fondly remember first meeting you
at Harvard when we were first postdocs
and I remember thinking when I first
started to talk with you hey that's a
real smart guy okay I better try to do
some physics with them and so as the
years went on we wrote a few papers
together we were we wrote one on super
gravity models for low energy
supersymmetry and one thing that most
people probably don't know is that you
actually wrote the code for solving
there were normalization group equations
well I was out tanning in the yard at at
Harvard we wrote a few papers together
probably the least well-known of them is
something titled on the generality of
the mass sum rule I think last time I
looked that had zero citations so
perhaps I'm on you're least cited paper
we had a lot of fun at Harvard doing
some physics and I also remember when we
first met taking a look at you and
thinking wow that's a real athletic
looking guy we got to do some sports
together so I'm hoping you remember that
we played squash well you'll see the
squash or racquetball something with a
racquet and a ball anyways we played we
had a lot of fun and I was trying to
remember what happened who won the most
games and I think I think that I won all
the games except for one or maybe it was
you who won all the games except for why
anyway it's not really very important so
I thought you should know that I've been
improving my game ever since we left if
I was to meet you today
it would certainly be no contest I would
just beat the pants off yet thought you
might have a little fun watching me play
don't let's try that again
well Joe as you can see my athletic
skills have never been finer and I'm
hoping you'll come one day to Caltech
and we'll play again for old times sake
hi Joe I'm outside of Caltech and
pursuing some of my recreational
activities I lurked when we met at at
John pres Cole's 60th celebration that
you've become a real athlete doing some
serious biking in your elderly years and
I likewise have taken up sports I'm now
involved in what might be called extreme
sports last weekend I was dropped from a
helicopter with a snowboard onto Mount
Everest and snowboard had all my way
down kind of surprising that I managed
to do that given that I'm afraid to go
beyond the third step of my ladder when
I trim the trees in my backyard but
nonetheless a few weekends I take on an
activity in extreme sports so today
we're going to be involved in extreme
skateboarding so we're getting ready to
go here I got John in the car my tether
safety is always important in extreme
sports so let me get my trusty helmet
okay let her rip John
[Music]
hi Joe
these extreme sports events always seem
to end this way to me on the ground but
anyways I just wanted to wish you a very
happy 60th birthday happy birthday Joe
that's it Joe
I'm told this tapestry has been here
forever oh the axe guy and that's the
Euler Lagrange equations so do I keep my
head nice shirt
yeah yep
look at that shot Joe you don't see that
too often do here
[Music]
let her rip
[Music]
did you film it all
well maybe we don't have to do that
forgot the helmet oh my god Oh
[Music]